samstagabend nachtleben in münchen
schlange stehen vor dem café kosmos hier
darf nur rein wer geimpft oder genesen
ist
2g heißt diese regelung es wird streng
kontrolliert
lena ist nicht geimpft und wollte sich
hier mit freunden treffen keine chance
dass man einfach so gezwungen wird zur
impfung weil man sonst nicht teil des
sozialen lebens sein kann und jetzt
gerade erlebe ich das live und hautnah
klasse als jemals zuvor quasi nicht cool
kein schönes gefühl
lena muss sich an diesem abend einen
anderen klub zum feiern suchen im café
kosmos bleiben geimpfte und genesene
unter sich
jeder muss für sich selbst entscheiden
was er macht und was er tut aber er muss
auch damit leben dass ihren
einschränkungen hat es ist voll die
menschen müssen wieder maske tragen noch
abstand halten
inhaber florian schönhofer war einer der
ersten der für sich entschied seinen
klub nur unter zwei bedingungen wieder
zu öffnen
war nicht so mir ist nach zweig sondern
lesen lesen lesen lesen und dann denkt
man sich okay jetzt habe ich meinem
personal geimpft ich bin geimpft ist
mein laden auf und lasst den leuten
geben nicht geimpft sind ja ist es denn
wirklich klug
fürsorglich fürs personal zu sein und
für die gäste nicht der shitstorm der
wegen dieser entscheidung zu 2g in den
sozialen netzwerken folgte überraschte
den gastronomen schön wäre die nachricht
café kosmos in münchen abgebrannt solche
arschgeigen wie dich braucht kein mensch
sei und dass das sind heute so die
sachen also viel so du sollst verbrennen
du sollst vergast werden da merkt man
heute schon wie rasend auf die sind oder
auch sauer und irgendwo in die ecke
getrieben ja
2g 3g viele gastronomen tun sich schwer
mit solchen entscheidungen die politik
in jedem bundesland anders manchmal sind
rein wirtschaftliche gründe entscheidend
denn zweig erlaubt es viel mehr gäste zu
bewirten da abstandsregeln und masken
pflicht wegfallen die branche zieht eine
kritische corona bilanz jahrestagung des
hotel und gaststättenverbandes
brandenburg gestern der präsident olaf
schöpe wird deutlich ich bin gegen
jegliche art von ausgrenzung und ich
wehre mich auch dagegen dass wir für die
politik jetzt an der stelle die
kastanien aus dem feuer holen sollen da
ich meine damit dass
durch diese angebliche freiwilligkeit
der g2 regel doch in gewisser druck
ausgeübt wird auch die kollegen der dann
nicht die g2 macht der darf eben keine
guten geschäfte machen das halte ich
durchaus für kritik mehr zuversicht und
optimismus wünschen sich die gastronomen
und hoteliers von der regierungstruppen
da passt es dass
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen jetzt
mehr normalität für alle verspricht dank
des enormen fortschritts bei den
impfungen viele viele menschen schützen
sich und andere durch impfungen können
wir den pandemischen ausnahmezustand
verlassen in einen zustand mit
besonderer vorsicht etwa mit drei geben
innenraum aber das signal ist sehr
wichtig die schwersten monate liegen
hinter uns wer das ende der pandemie
verspricht er wecke erwartungen die
nicht zu erfüllen seien kritisiert
gesundheitsexperte karl lauterbach
noch sei es zu früh
wenn es uns gelingt
sagte bei den über 65 also über 90
prozent geht zu haben und bei denen also
erwachsenen insgesamt also über 80
prozent dann also sind öffnungen
möglich um die nicht geimpften menschen
zu erreichen fordert der
gesundheitsökonom professor jonas
schreier einen strategiewechsel weniger
politischen druck bei der impf debatte
seine jüngste befragung kommt zu dem
ergebnis dass 19 prozent der bevölkerung
über 18 nicht geimpft ist
geschlecht und bildungsgrad spielten
dabei keine rolle
67 prozent der impfwilligen fühle sich
von der politik unter druck gesetzt wir
stellen fest dass wenn wenn man im
ungeimpfte nach nach ihrer reaktion frau
erfragt in bezug auf zweig oder
kostenpflichtige tests dass viele mit
trotz reagieren und sagen ihre
impfbereitschaft wird sich dadurch nicht
erhöhen sondern er sogar ein drittel
sagt dass die impfbereitschaft dadurch
eher sinkt
astrid winter ist marketingleiterin wie
erreichen sie per skype die mutter von
zwei kindern ist nicht gegen cupid
geimpft als querdenkerin sieht sie sich
nicht sie hat angst vor der impfung weil
ihr immunsystem durch eine borreliose
geschwächt ist erzählt sie
ja den fokus auf die eigenverantwortung
setzen und nicht auf irgendwelche
druck und zwang maßnahmen und mit jeder
maßnahme die oben drauf kommt rückt die
bevölkerung ein bisschen weiter
auseinander und
das finde ich extrem traurig das macht
mich auch ein bisschen wesen
der streit ums impfen spaltet das spürt
auch die teil überging als chef mit
friderizianischen dreispitz bemüht er
sich ängste und sorgen seiner gäste im
campingpark potsdam zu vertreiben am
eingang stehen für fünf euro tests
bereit im restaurant anna amalia bleibt
die dreijährige bestehen und das ist ja
das große probleme die so 2 und 3 g
regelung die wir haben dass eine
spaltung der gesellschaft vor
tritt und das möchte ich gar nicht
verhindern deswegen sage ich ja auch
mein demokratieverständnis
3g jeder darf kommen
deshalb verzichtet er wird auf 30 bis 40
prozent seiner einnahmen denn die tische
müssen ein meter fünfzig abstand haben
wir machen uns natürlich auch deswegen
weil einige unserer mitarbeiter nicht
geimpft sind und die dürften auch bei
der zweig regelungen dann nicht mehr bei
uns arbeiten und gerade in der heutigen
zeit mit dem fachkräftemangel ist es
natürlich auch schon land schwierig
über ding wird weiter arbeiten für ein
möglichst entspanntes miteinander in
zeiten von corona die sorge das virus
und pandemie die konflikte weiter
verschärfen bleibt